[Música]
poco se dice de nicolás t no fuera de
una clase de geología pero quien quiera
entender la vida en la tierra debería
ver la forma en que éste no expandió y
conecto estos conceptos tierra vida y
entendimiento nacido como nils extensión
en dinamarca en 1638 hijo de un orfebre
era un niño enfermizo cuyos compañeros
murieron de plaga como anatomista
disección o cadáveres para estudiar
cuales órganos comparten las especies
encontró un conducto en los cráneos de
animales que envían saliva a la boca
refutó la idea de de kart de que la
glándula pineal era el asiento del alma
en lo que podría ser el debut de la
neurociencia lo más notable para la
época fue su método este no nunca dejó
que textos antiguos como la meta física
aristotélica o la filosofía cartesiana
invalidarán la evidencia empírica y
experimental su visión despojada de
especulación o racionalización fue
profunda éste no notó que la formación
de cálculos biliares en órganos húmedos
obedecían a principio
de moldeo que conocía de la orfebrería
reglas útiles en todas las disciplinas
para entender los sólidos después el
gran duque de toscana le pidió
diseccionar un tiburón sus dientes
parecían lenguas de piedra rocas
extrañas dentro de otras rocas en malta
y florencia usted no vio que las piedras
de lengua tenían el mismo crecimiento
estructural que los dientes de tiburón
pensó que por su similitud los dientes
venían de antiguos tiburones de aguas
que formaron roca alrededor de los
dientes y se convirtieron en montañas
las capas de roca alguna vez fueron
sedimentos acuosos que yacen unos sobre
otros en orden de antigüedad si se
deformaron inclinaron o cortaron por una
falla ese cambio fue después de la
formación de la capa hoy suena sencillo
en ese entonces era revolucionario había
inventado la estratigrafía y sentó las
bases de la geología encontró el origen
de los dientes de tiburón de dos eras al
señalar que las leyes naturales que
rigen el presente
en rigieron el pasado así usted no
sembró las semillas del uniformismo en
los siglos 18 y 19 los geólogos
uniformistas ingleses james hutton y
charles life estudiaron las lentas tasas
de erosión y sedimentación y notaron que
la tierra tenía que ser mucho más
antigua que el cálculo bíblico de seis
mil años de su trabajo surgió el ciclo
de las rocas que combinado con la
tectónica de placas a mediados del siglo
20 nos dieron la gran teoría de la
tierra que va desde un cálculo biliar a
un planeta de 4.500 millones de años
ahora piensa en grande llévalo a la
biología digamos que ves dientes de
tiburón en una capa y por debajo el
fósil de un organismo nunca antes visto
el fósil más profundo es más antiguo
si ahora tienes evidencia del origen y
la extinción de las especies a través
del tiempo quizá un proceso aún activo
hoy provocó cambios no sólo en las rocas
sino en la vida también podría explica
las similitudes y diferencias entre
especies anotadas por anatomistas como
éste no charles darwin reflexionó sobre
esto en un largo viaje a las galápagos a
leer el libro de su amigo charles life
principios de geología que en cierto
modo éste no fundó nicolás éste no ayudó
a desarrollar la evolución sentó las
bases de la geología y mostró que la
observación imparcial y empírica puede
traspasar las fronteras intelectuales
su mayor logro sin embargo puede ser su
máxima que presenta la búsqueda de la
verdad más allá de nuestros sentidos y
nuestra comprensión como la búsqueda de
la belleza de lo desconocido hermoso es
lo que vemos más hermoso es lo que
sabemos y lo más hermoso con creces es
lo que no sabemos